hello my name is Neffe I met at a lodge
for Empire magazine and I'm here to say
as little as possible and let this man
to over talking before you go into
writing professionally there's just a
period of time where you worked it's not
a clear trajectory like I did this then
I worked in politics then I did this so
in the midst around the same time I was
writing that first play my best friend a
guy named Jay Carson he's the character
the character Steve and in Ides of March
period North is based on him he was
having this meteoric rise that already
began in college and he said I'm working
on the Senate campaign why don't you
come work on it and I did and I had a
blast it was an amazing experience we
were all over the state you know a
couple twenty-year-old guys feeling like
in our own infinite small way we were we
were gonna make a difference and make
history and we won that race and it was
amazing I mean there's very few things
in life where you know on a particular
day at a particular time whether you had
succeeded or failed an election is one
of those things and it's as I learned at
that time such a rush such a high when
you win and as I learned later so
crushing when you lose it's very black
and white but we won and I wanted more
and that led to Hillary Clinton's Senate
race in 2000 a bill Bradley's
presidential in 2000 and alternately
Howard Dean's presidential in 2004 which
is the last campaign I've ever worked on
I guess over ten years ago now and I
drew from all those experiences to write
faragut and write and continue to draw
on them to write house of cards but
politics was never like a thing for me
I'm not a political junkie I I've
written 12 plays and only one of them
has to do with politics and you know the
reason you guys probably showed up is
because the house of cards and and so
the two things that I'm most known for
Farragut North in Ides of March on the
one hand and house of cards and the
other both are you know in the world of
politics but that's not a subject that
interests me power no no no I'm not
trying to be cavalier here power really
interests me in politics is a subset of
power and politics in Washington at this
level you're seeing power explored in
the most sophisticated ways with the
highest stakes but I'm just as
interested in fascinated by the power
relationship within the marriage between
Frank and Claire underwood which is the
real subject of the show not politics if
that makes sense so can we talk a little
bit about how how close the Farragut was
to your own experience or your friends
experience but also then these parents
are seen by staged and then I can't
imagine what it's like to get a phone
call from George Clooney or clean these
people saying hey we think you've got
something here we'd like to make a movie
I had never the most that I'd ever had
with that play is a staged reading
before I got the call from Warner
Brothers that they want to turn into a
movie it had never been on stage in fact
I'd sent it to 40 theaters around the
country I didn't have an agent at the
time and those that got back to me
rejected it and most didn't even get
back to me so I put that play away and I
began working on subsequent plays and
when I got the call it was because you
know I won't go into all the details
after I wrote that play I managed to get
an agent and that agent read my work and
said I want to send this play out I said
good luck of Senate everywhere but he he
sent out he immediately got some
interest from Broadway theater producers
which was crazy because I had never had
a single production of anything but
based on that my agent felt encouraged
enough to send it out to wakka send it
out to Hollywood just as a writing
sample in the hopes that I might get
some meetings and maybe get like a
staffing job on a TV show or something
but somehow in the way that these things
happen in their magical way it
ended up at a junior executives desk at
Warner Brothers who read it he was about
my age he immediately gave it to his
boss a guy named Kevin McCormack who was
an executive at Warner Bros for many
years and a brilliant guy and he had a
discretionary fund so he could just put
something in development without having
to go to anyone else and we got a call
saying we'd like to turn this plane to a
movie and George Clooney and Leo
DiCaprio want to produce remember I've
never had a production of a play I was I
was temping at a place in Rockefeller
Plaza where my job was to staple things
and put them in the mail and I said let
me think about it I'll get back to you
next week no III shat myself and then
when I clean that up we you know I went
out to LA and I met with you know
George's people and eventually George
and and Leo and and the Warner Brothers
folks and it was happening you know
so rewiring my brain to that which was
totally new for me was hard but also
thrilling and I did a few drafts and
then I turned it over to George Clooney
and grant Heslov and they worked off
those drafts and did their drafts and at
the point I handed it off my work was
done it was very much at that point
gonna be George's movie I mean he was
directing it he was in it
he had pulled together the cast which
was an amazing cast and he had found the
financing and he had wrested away from
Warner Brothers to get it distributed by
Sony which never had it's very difficult
to wrest a property away from one studio
for to go to another so it's very much
his thing and and they did their work
and they changed a lot and I and a lot
of the screenplay for that movie is then
and and I was fine with that because I
knew they understood the core of the
story and they didn't want to
with that and that was this young man at
this fork in the road having this great
sort of ethical choice before him and he
chooses one direction another and in the
moment he chooses this directions the
moment he becomes a monster and it's
that moment of becoming a monster which
I wanted to arrive at and that is what
they achieved I think in the film in a
way that was very different from the
play and they got beautiful performances
out of out of every one and I'm very
proud of the work that we all did but
particularly grateful to George for
being so passionate about it making it
happen because those sort of movies I
mean look around they're not getting
made anymore certainly well at least not
in America as much if you don't have a
comic book hero good luck you know and
and so I mean all in all for me it was
incredibly positive experience and it
opened up it opened up that door that I
got my pinky toe into and you know I
there's no doubt in my mind that I
wouldn't be sitting here if it wasn't
for a number of people Kevin McCormick
the junior exec that worked for him
George Clooney grant has saw all the
actors that said yes that film the
people that put the money into it but
weren't for all those people taking a
chance on this piece of material by
someone who had no credits whatsoever
then you know I'd still be stapling
stuff and mailing it so you have
Farragut North and you get the cool
about doing the movie but then you go
you know after an oscar-nominated and
then a cool about house of cards so
you've written first stage you've been
written for the big screen
was there any hesitancy then by going
well now I've got to learn how to write
for television and is that much of a
different experience yeah again it's a
little messy because it's not that
linear the way I'd gotten that agent
which is how I to March happen is I by
writing a pilot for AMC AMC's the
network that did Mad Men and Breaking
Bad and Walking Dead but when I got the
gig
they were just starting and a good
friend of mine Sam Forman it had a
really good meeting with them he had an
agent he was he'd had shows produced on
the stage and they had said to him we
love your spec script we're looking for
three things as we start this new
venture of original content we're
looking for period pieces espionage
pieces or smart horror and do you have
any of those things and Sam said I do
not and they said come back when you do
and he said okay and then Sam and I went
for a drink and he said do you have any
ideas for period espionage or smart
horror and I said what the [ __ ] is smart
horror he's like I have no idea I guess
it's the walking dead right but but
we're like okay we don't we don't know
what smart horror is so our best bet
here is espionage short period and then
there was a few screenplays that I wrote
one one was a blind script for Warner
Brothers that was part of the Ides of
March deal I hubristic Lee tried to
tackle Tale of Two Cities I was like the
sixth writer in 20 years to try to make
that happen for Warner Brothers and I
think I wrote a good script and I think
the five scripts before me were also
really good they just they couldn't
commit and then I wrote a couple other
screenplays and that didn't get made and
and I was sort of at this moment where I
go well I had this movie that George
Clooney made and got nominated for this
stuff and I got my foot in the door and
now I've had three scripts that haven't
gotten made I mean it may be ending I
mean you know that you can only write so
many scripts that don't get made before
people stopped hiring you to write
scripts and it was right at that moment
that Fincher called and said have you
heard of this thing called house of
cards they want to make a TV show and
I'd heard of it because if you write
anything about politics at some point
someone's gonna say did you watch house
of cards and at that time they meant
just the BBC version ours didn't exist
so I've been meaning to watch it anyway
and I I figured well Fincher is one of
the great living filmmakers and within
like 10
Ekans you realize when you're talking
david fincher they you're dealing with
the sort of mind that you may never
encounter again I mean he has a savant
like knowledge of the craft in the
history of filmmaking he is incredibly
clever and witty but also concise and
deep and blunt and profound in his
thinking about art he his his synapses
fire faster than just about anyone I
know
and I just felt through the phone like I
was dealing with this life force that I
wanted to tap into I wanted to hold on
to and and work with and be around and
we started talking about house of cards
and you know we had similar instincts on
the approach to it and we were starting
to come up with new ideas on the fly
and it just became clear that like I I
had to do this we're gonna open
questions from the audience in a couple
of minutes I just wanted to know that's
good I mean I shouldn't have prepared so
much I could have gone to the pub yeah
structure see if the structure a play
you have the structure of a film how
does the structure differ when you're
doing television or does it differ that
much given that it's not really cheap
you know oh yeah everything's dropping
the same time yeah well for me TVs a lot
closer to the theater because there's an
ongoing dialogue with the actors and the
department heads I can you it's like you
have this crew and this family that
you're spending a lot of time with and
discovering things with as you would in
the rehearsal process for a play and
something that you discover and say
episode 2 even though you've planned out
the whole season might influence scripts
to come and have this ripple effect and
so there's a lot more dialogue between
the collaborators going back and forth
then I think you have on a film where
most the time you have the script and
then the director takes it and directs
it there's also the the fact that you
you have you know just one season for us
13 hours a film a movie is much more
like a short story or a poem like that
not a moment or line that can be wasted
like it has to resolve itself in 90 to
120 minutes and with the television show
it doesn't I mean each hour chapter
whatever you want to call it is a
discrete thing that has its own
beginning middle and an end to a degree
but it doesn't have to completely
resolve itself I mean it could actually
end in a place of total lack of
resolution but the feeling you're
heading in somewhere so you can really
take your time with the storytelling you
can I think dive into character in ways
that are impossible to do in film or
even a stage play because you have the
hours to do it and in that way I think
it's some closest to a novel more than
anything else which is also how people
are watching it too these days they're
sort of picking it up and putting it
down when they want to and choosing how
many chapters they want to read and you
have no control over that the same way
that novelist doesn't have any control
over you know whether you read their
novel on the train or in your living
room in one sitting or over the course
of many months so you know the approach
that Fincher wanted to take and that I
guess we I mean I didn't know any better
I mean none of us have made TV you know
we didn't really know what we were doing
but we just figured okay well we'll make
a movie that just happens to be 13 hours
long and I can't describe to you what
that means
other than that's what we tried to do
and I think that's what a season is for
us so we don't really think about
episodes as much as we think about this
the movie and we just have a lot longer
movie and more time to play with than
the typical film
so if we have a couple of roving mics so
if you have a question can you take your
hand in the air let's start over here in
house of cards season one and I think
every state eight or nine Francis offers
Doug to teach him how to play chess my
question is would duck fit much better
if he'd taken up that offer well sort of
more generally speaking and how fast
chess maybe an organizing principle to
the entire show I believe when Francis
offered to teach Stamper how to play
chess claire had disappeared off to New
York to be with Adam Galloway and he was
feelings in this Restless purgatory and
Stamper if anything is functional it's
about control it's about getting things
done in a very practical way and he
wasn't certainly not in season one
equipped I think to deal with the
emotional limbo that his boss was in so
better to just get away I don't I've
never thought about it in terms of would
he have fared better if he had learned
how to play chess I don't know maybe I
mean chess is and this bleeds into your
second question I guess
I mean chess to me is is fascinating I
mean I I I wrote a play about Garry
Kasparov smash against deep blue in 1997
and I'm not I'm not even an amateur
chess player I mean I I can hold my own
I guess with the average player out
there but its vast I mean it's I mean I
read that there were more possible games
of chess than there are particles in the
universe and when studying someone like
a Gary Kasparov that it was actually
someone I brought up a lot in my early
conversations with Fincher what's
interesting about Kasparov and the
reason
he's one of the greatest players of all
time is not because of his strategy or
tactics it's not that he's thinking 15
moves ahead it's that he's creating
chaos on the board he will sacrifice two
pieces for seemingly no reason
whatsoever with not necessarily a
concrete plan on how to get back that
capital but he knows that the person on
other side of the table saying why did
he just do that he must have some grand
plan he must be thinking 15 moves ahead
and at that level with Grand Master's
it's about it's like tennis who makes
the first mistake so if I know I'm
willingly making this mistake but what I
get back is I'm psychologically throwing
off the other guy who will make a bigger
mistake then it then it's worth it and
that's something we we we use all the
time with Frank Underwood you know to
steal one of the lines from the show if
you don't like the way the table is set
turn over the table and something that
Finch and I talked a lot about was that
politics is not about it's it's not a
symphony it's jazz it is call and
response
it is reaction the great politicians
might plan out 15 steps ahead but don't
get to step 2 and everything changes
there's some crisis there's some
unexpected thing there there is the
chaos the world and at that moment you
have to get rid of the next 13 steps and
you have to react to that and develop a
new plan that you know will the next day
probably thrown out the window because
of new chaos introducing itself and it's
how do you manage that chaos and make it
work for you how do you play jazz with
it that really makes the great
politicians great and then the very best
politicians know how to create chaos and
make it work for them so yeah I mean I
guess in that respect
yeah I'm not thinking about chess all
the time as a right house of cards but
there's certainly
finding parallels to be drawn does that
metaphor whole tree for the prices of
actually writing the show as well of
kind of you may be thinking oh this is
gonna happen oh yeah a teen but all
things challenge totally I mean from
from creative discoveries to things
they're simply out of our control
creative discoveries might be something
like in season 1 Peter Russo's character
was a big character but never intended
to be the guy who ran for governor that
was a whole other character but Corey
Stoll was so great and when we saw him
on screen with Kevin we all felt just
would want to see more of that I mean
that that's lightning in a bottle that
we've caught that you don't wanna let
that light and go so I made a huge shift
in the middle of filming the season
where I took this other character story
who was running for governor and I gave
it to Peter Russo and that's not just
about changing whose name is above the
dialog that required page one rewrites
from episode 5 onwards but it was in
response to this discovery we had made
and it was totally worth it because it
actually made Peter Russo story stronger
it consolidated the story for the season
so we were really focusing on this one
guy as opposed to two and you know it
worked for us there are other instances
where you know you might lose an actor I
mean in the States you can have series
regular deals and forgive me for being a
little jargony here but a series regular
deal means that you basically own the
actor then you have them in a first
position they can't do anything else
unless they get permission from you but
there's a lot of characters that you
don't have in first position because you
can't afford it
so they might be a lot in a fair number
of episodes and you kind of count on
their existence but they get some big
offer from another thing and boom
they're gone and then you you built this
story around this person that is no
longer available to you you have no
choice but to change your story and
react to it so I'm not going to name
names but I mean that has happened
before for us and you know look
here's a tiny one it wasn't global but
you know you you guys remember in season
1 episode 9 I think the where Francis
says I I despise children there I said
it
and in the beginning of that episode
he's talking about stuff with Peter
Russo Russo's kids are running around
one of her says kids knock some caulking
it burns his hand and he said I despise
children and I said it and then the rest
of the episode you see him wearing a
bandage well Kevin had actually injured
his hand and there was his bandage there
and we didn't want to deal with having
to shoot everything where we were hiding
his hand so I created that opening to
the show so that we could justify him
wearing a bandage but then I'm like well
I might as well make the most of it
let's have him say he despises children
you know and it's one of my favorite
directed dresses but that's just you
know that's the chaos of the world you
know firstly about the Ides of March
which is a film I love very much and
fortunately saw it in New York and it
was a really fantastic experience for us
when it came out you touch slightly on
your with your research which obviously
for that came from your experience so
firstly what tools do you use for
researching for other things other
projects and the other aspect is about
the male and the female voice within
your work as a writer so within the eyes
of marchi you know it was quite a male
heavy film you had very strong female
voices and this is also existent within
house of cards how to use a male writer
right so well for women well thank you
for liking Ides of March and for the
compliment you paid at the end writing
well for women I mean I I'll start with
the second part first which is that it's
not just me writing well for women it's
also the women I employ on my writing
staff you know which is an important
thing to do if you are going to have
female characters in your show that said
I don't I really am against the notion
that the female writers should write the
female characters and the male writers
write the male characters I mean what is
writing if not the attempt to put
yourself in other people's shoes so I
expect my female writers to be able to
write men well to the best of their
ability and and vice versa
now we're all limited by our own
experiences there are certain things I
will never be able to access because of
things that are genetic things that are
in my upbringing things that are
cultural we all have our limited
horizons and often our unconscious
biases but I think writing is an attempt
to acknowledge those and sometimes get
beyond them and find the universal and
all of our experiences so we the way we
approach writing men and women on a
house of cards it's paradoxical on the
one hand we want to be gender blind I
mean there's there's know all the
characters are equally intelligent and
venal and I mean Balzac's one of my
favorite writers because the women in in
stories are just as insidious as
everyone else
and and I think that you know we're
looking for the strength and also the
weakness in every character and you know
there's a term that is I don't know if
it's used here often but certainly in
the States like strong female characters
I take a little bit of issue with strong
female characters as though you know why
do you have to put the word strong in
front of it you know I mean there are
strong male characters and weak male
characters there are strong female
characters and weak female characters
there are strong and weak trans
characters you can kind of look at a
spectrum and you know one end of the
spectrum is misogyny and neglect
misogyny we all know what that means but
there's a sort of indirect form of
misogyny which is like the absence of
female characters or or substantial
storylines for them or that they're just
relegated to their body or just to their
relationship to a man
right so that's one end in spectrum
that's bad
the other end of the spectrum is trying
to place women on some sort of pedestal
you know trying to make them these sort
of goddesses or fantasies and and almost
trying too hard to make them strong you
know which is which is another way
actually neglecting the complexity of
their lives so if you avoid those two
ends and just say well we're just going
to say this character man or woman has a
need what is that thing that they need
and what are they do willing to do to to
get that need then then you can begin to
I think address gender in a
sophisticated way obviously there are
certain things that are different in the
human experience between men and women
if Frank Underwood were having
perimenopausal hot flashes that would be
strange may that's not an experience a
guy is gonna have it is an experience
that women can and will have so we told
that story for Claire in part and season
one but here's the big thing that wasn't
her her story that was part of her life
but if we had said this is her story and
her story is only one that is relegated
to something that's gender specific then
that we would have been reductive with
her but if we're just telling the story
of Claire under what edit so happens
because she's this age that this is
something she's going through then we're
just being realistic so I don't know if
that answers your question but that's
that's how we try to approach it and
then the first party to cook the food oh
research so for a house of cards it's a
mixture of book learning of experts Jay
Carson the guy talked about earlier is
our political consultant if he doesn't
know something he puts us in touch with
people that are it's my own personal
experience and it's also my writers own
personal
experience and oftentimes the research
is not so much political it's drawing
from you know you can see something
happen on its side walk like a man
screaming you know a homeless man
screaming on a sidewalk that's research
if you absorb it if it means something
to you if you find yourself using it and
colliding it with your character you
know so I think it's about being open on
other subject matter like the like Gary
Kasparov I mean same same thing I mean
it's really a project specific but it's
you know the adage right what you know I
think is a very wise one but also it's
important to write what you don't know
if only to discover the things that you
know that you didn't know I nearly
gotten where I got into NYU Tisch
earlier this year but the same time we
got an agent to my scripts were picked
up and I'm developing one of them now it
is a sitcom which is kind of a weird
experience but I was asking you is there
any advice you can give for the next
steps I'm in because it's all based
around uncertainty and have really no
idea apart from that no ideas I have my
head about what I'm creating yeah is
there any advice I the only real advice
I could give is to do the work I mean I
you know I always struggle when writers
ask for advice because you know there's
no formula I mean Congrats on getting an
agent
Congrats on NYU it's a great school and
I mean it sounds like you were you're
creating the opportunities for yourself
that are beginning to pay off and and
you know a big part of any form of
success in any industry is is you know
looking for opportunities and then
making opportunities if they're not
being laid at your feet and that can be
school it could be going out and making
your own film on your own it
be you know if no one is doing any of
your pilot's writing a play and doing
that with your friends you know no one
can stop you from that there's a million
ways to create opportunities for
yourself but ultimately all of that is
only there if you've got the pages the
only thing you can do that is completely
your control and it ultimately will make
you successful at least financially or
whatever as a form of success although
the real success has nothing to do with
that but is having the pages and putting
in the time and the thousands of hours
and thousands of pages you must write I
I don't think that talking about what
you're writing counts I don't think
thinking about what you want to write
counts I think the only thing that
counts is the actual writing so you know
if you've got a sitcom that's getting
some traction you know there's a lot of
strategic things that you know if we sat
down for now and talked about you know
this agent is doing this and going to
this studio and there's all that
[ __ ] that's you know the
strategically but no matter what happens
you're either gonna be making your show
in which case it's not about buying a
new car and you know going to all the
clubs it's about you got to put your
shoulder to the wheel even more or
you're not going to make your show in
which case the only thing that you can
do is write the next one and then write
the next one and then write the next one
and then write the next one and the next
one and the next one and the next one
and never stop until you die
you know my first thought my first time
I see not my first thought every day
when I wake up like my mantra as soon as
I have the ability of a conscious
thought its I will die right which
sounds morbid but it's not to me it's
completely liberating because it can't
get worse from there like you you have
that thought and you go okay let's get
to work you know so that's a piece of
advice to just remember that every day
when you wake up let's put things in
perspective that seems like a wonderful
moment
what's to end our evening thank you so
much because all that mattered was the
story nothing else not your ego not your
training not your ambitions this story
is all I care about you know we were in
this production office in Dublin and I I
went upstairs and I borrowed somebody's
computer and I wrote the scene in
probably 30 minutes
you